it's great to welcome to the program
today Erin Hamlin who's the executive
director of the Center for election
science Erin so great to have you on
really appreciate you joining me today
great thanks for having me so to begin
with most people in our audience I think
are relatively familiar with what is
called ranked choice voting a method
whereby one as the name suggests ranks
the candidates for any particular
election or office on the basis of their
preference number one being the most
preferred candidate and we've explored
that as an alternative to the voting
system that we have a little bit to kind
of continue our conversation where we
may have most recently left it off with
the audience give us your sense of where
you see rank-choice voting falling in
terms of preference as an alternative
voting system what are its pros what are
its cons so I would say rank trees 13 is
a moderate improvement over what we have
now particularly it deals well with
elections where you have I say two major
party candidates and a third party or
independent candidate where the third
party or independent candidate doesn't
do particularly well we're a wreck
towards 30 can struggle is where there
are more than two candidates in a very
competitive election so that third
fourth or fifth candidate isn't just
getting a sliver of the vote they're
getting a substantial amount of the vote
and in those types of elections break
for authority can have some issues which
is unfortunate because those are really
exciting elections where voters have a
lot of options
okay so let's explore what the issues
are I guess we can think of as an
example Ross Perot I mean it's been a
while now but he was one of the non top
two candidates who had a pretty
significant level of support at least in
a presidential election in in a scenario
like that you're saying rank-choice
voting is less optimal as a system why
why is that yeah potentially and it's
not to say that these issues will creep
up every time so as an example there was
an actual election and Burlington
Vermont
they used ranked
voting and 2009 there the idea going in
was you can always rank your own as
favorite as first but the issue came up
there for conservative voters there were
three major candidates in that race
there was a Progressive Party candidate
Democratic candidate and Republican
candidate and what happened was as
conservative voters they ranked their
favorite candidate the Republican
candidate as first and what happened was
there was some boat spinning that had
gone on so that the Democrat candidate
had the fewest number of first choice
votes so the Democratic candidate was
eliminated and their votes were
transferred over and there were enough
votes from the Democrat candidate to
move over to the progressive candidate
for the progressive candidate to win now
what's interesting about that is that
had those conservative voters actually
either not voted at all or had they
instead of ranking the Republican is
first the Democrat is first they would
have gotten a better outcome and so
these issues where voters are punished
for ranking they're honest a word is
first can come up and also kind of
quirks like non monotonicity which is
when you can make it candidate is better
and it can wind up hurting in that
candidate okay so one of the ideas that
some have suggested to resolve that
particular issue would be instead of
something like ranked choice voting to
consider like a single transferable vote
can you talk about how that system is
different from rank-choice voting and
how it would deal with the particular
issue you brought up from the Vermont
race so transferable vote is a multi
winner method that uses a similar type
of calculation process as rank choice
voting but they're completely different
so the existence of single transferable
vote doesn't address any of the issues
within night race voting so with rank
choice voting it's a single winner
voting method for executive type offices
a single transferable vote is a multi
winner voting method for at-large
offices
so therefore completely different
scenarios so when people write in to me
and they say David you should talk more
about single transferable vote in order
to address the issues of ranked choice
voting these are actually systems that
are designed for different types of
elections altogether completely
different types of elections yes
is there a modification that could be
made to rank-choice voting as you just
described it to deal with the issues
you've identified no okay all right so
let's talk about that that will get us
very quickly into another system that I
want to bring up to the audience which
we've not talked about as much which is
called approval voting and approval
voting as I understand it and I know
that you'll expand on this is the idea
that you can identify on a ballot that
has multiple candidates all of the
candidates who you would be effectively
okay with being in the office they are
running four it doesn't include that
ranking mechanism but you're saying of
the ten candidates here's three that
would be acceptable to me and the idea
is you sort of build a consensus as to
who is most I guess you would say
plurally acceptable to the voting public
to determine the winner that's right
yeah and you kind of get at it which is
it's the voter that decides which but
that threshold is in terms of where they
approve or where they don't approve a
particular candidate and when you vote
in this way different people might be
casting a ballot one could say for a
different number of candidates which I
know immediately gets people thinking of
does this violate one-person one-vote
ultimately I'm guessing that the answer
is no once there are these kind of
initial tabulations ultimately you're
really only in practice voting for the
person who has the plurality of support
but how do we more on a technical basis
address this issue of does that violate
one-person one-vote sure so one person
one vote goes back to Supreme
Court decisions looking at different
populations within districts there you
could have a small district that has say
a tenth of this many people is another
district but they're both getting the
same number of people elected so the
smaller district is electing it has ten
times more weight than the than the
larger district here are we're talking
about expression within a ballot which
is going after something completely
different so our ballots have the same
weight even if we choose different
numbers of candidates on those ballots
so if you choose one person and I choose
four different people I've chosen four
times as many people as you have and yet
if we add our ballots up together we
have a five-way tie so I haven't gotten
in the particular weight advantage from
my ballot just by the mere fact that
I've chosen more candidates one of the
problems you identified with rank-choice
voting is that the winner in a ranked
choice in Aereo may not actually have
won in some or all of the hypothetical
head-to-head matchups that could be kind
of configured from a group of three or
more candidates
how does approval voting relate to the
results that we would expect in
hypothetical head-to-head matchups
between the different candidates so when
we're talking about head-to-head
matchups here and dodi method speak we
call this a Condorcet winner someone who
can win and all these head-to-head
matchups neither approval voting nor
ranked choice voting satisfy this
particular criterion approval voting in
hypothetical situations and looking at
it does a very good job of electing what
we would call this conversate winner
this candidate who can beat everyone
else head-to-head and there are some
elections that rank-choice voting has a
particularly difficult time with that
such as when you have more than two
competitive candidates how does this
relate to the question of the electoral
vote versus popular vote
the united states and to kind of provide
some context to the question typically
the limit let me actually backtrack
often the advocates of an alternative
voting system be it approval voting rank
choice voting single transferable vote
for different types of elections also
tend to favor getting away from the
electoral college at the national level
are the two issues related or can the
decisions about single transferable vote
or approval voting or whatever be made
as completely separate decisions from
the broader electoral versus popular
vote system that we have in the united
states nationally so there are all kinds
of different offices other than the
president presidential office so when
we're talking about say like a city
council or a state legislature we can
talk about these multi winner
proportional methods like single
transferable vote or others but when
we're talking about specifically the
presidential election it's it's kind of
strange because we had this electoral
vote system and so there it actually
does make a difference in terms of what
alternative voting method we integrate
with a national popular vote because in
addition to the types of winners that a
voting method can select there are also
some technical components as well so
when we're trying to tabulate vote at
the national scale there's also
something called precinct so mobility a
feature that some voting methods have so
precinct some ability means that you can
tabulate totals for a voting method at
the local level pick those totals and
then add them for the another higher
level like a national level approval
voting it's really easy to add up those
votes you can add them at the state
level take all the sums of the different
states put them together you got a
national popular vote but you can't do
that with some other methods like Frank
Torre Snowden there you need all that
valid data together in one place
what really complicates this issue so
let me see if I understand if you have
rank choice voting at the state level
the way in which those individual state
level elections would be tabulated don't
it as easily lend themselves to and
during the simple question of what is
the national popular vote result because
of the algorithm that's used that's
right in terms of getting those type of
Asians to add up with other with other
states
assuming they also use ranked choice
voting the other issue there is that
ranked choice voting say you have States
using different voting methods like our
current voting method of choosing one
candidate and another state using my
tourist outing and they're all trying to
figure out what the national popular
vote is for a president well you can't
add up right choice balance or ordinal
ranking balance alongside or choose one
balance but we can do is if you have
States that are kind of not matching in
terms of the voting method you can add
up approval voting ballots with our
current trees one ballots that data can
add up together but you can't do that
with ranking methods and our current
trees one method that's interesting so
if states are not using the same method
if some states decide to go ranked
choice other states decide to keep the
system we have some other states might
say we want to do approval voting or
whatnot
it actually reinforces keeping the
electoral method where each state is
essentially holding its own election and
saying here's how our electors are going
to vote because of this kind of in
congruence between the different methods
that's right
trying to use ranked race voting and had
that coincide with a national popular
vote
it just doesn't mesh at all okay so if a
priority was to replace the electoral
college with a national popular vote
which systems are the ones that would
actually work with that the easiest one
really would be approval voting and it's
because of those two factors one its
precinct summable which from a pragmatic
point of view makes it a lot easier and
then secondly it works well with holdout
states set on using approval voting yet
can you explain that so if you have one
or two states or however many that have
not switched over to that how is it that
those results from those states would be
integrated
sure so you have like you're normally
your normal results from an election
where trees only one candidate there be
a certain number of votes for each
particular candidate with the people
voting you have the same thing you have
a certain number of votes for each
candidate and at the the total may add
up to more than the total number of
voters because voters can choose more
than one but you can so just add those
up together so there's no issue there
absolutely fascinating stuff that we
will of course continue to cover
particularly as different states
consider different voting methods we've
been speaking with Erin Hamlin who's the
executive director of the center for
election science Erin really a pleasure
having you on today thank you very much